[Musique]
aujourd'hui les défis auxquels l'europe
est confrontée
c'est notamment ceux du terrorisme ceux
de l'immigration et à ces titres-là
l'europe effectivement peut avoir une
action elle peut renforcer ses
frontières elle peut protéger les
frontières extérieures maintenir la
sécurité la paix et en europe
endiguer les flux d'immigration illégale
et pour protéger les citoyens de chacun
des pays membres
d'éventuelles attaques terroristes je
souhaiterais une europe moins
technocratique
voilà que qu'ils soient à la portée de
tout le monde des projets actuellement
comprend nous avons la chance en europe
d'avoir des fleurons industriels des
grandes entreprises qui produisent qui
ont une renommée internationale
nous devons absolument protéger ses
entreprises il faut que l'europe pro
devienne une europe des producteurs et
non plus que des consommateurs il faut
aussi préserver en fait les entreprises
européennes face à la mondialisation et
face aux autres puissances une europe
avec moins de normes et une
harmonisation fiscale et sociale une
europe de l'investissement une europe
qui doit continuer la recherche qui doit
continuer les projets culturels comme
erasmus approfondir toutes ces
dynamiques
l'europe doit fumer c'est sa culture
on a une très belle culture européenne
je pense on peut être français aux
philosophes grecs aux juristes romain et
il faut la réaffirmer la diffuser le
plus largement possible s'est imposé en
fait non plus sur la scène
internationale ça serait de peser de
devenir un véritable une véritable
puissance qui face aux états unis face à
la chine
face à la russie puisse parler d'égal à
égal l'un des grands défis européens
c'est d'arrêter l'élargissement dans de
nouveaux pays
[Musique]